liberal governors in new york and new
jersey announcing strict new measures as
coveted cases rise across the country
joe biden has recently promised he was
shut down the virus
not the country but one of his top covet
advisors
is contradicting that pledge big time
listen to this we could pay for a
package right now
to cover the all of the wages lost wages
for individual workers
for losses to small companies to
medium-sized companies
for city states county governments we
could do all that if we did that then we
could
lock down for four to six weeks when
asked about the lockdowns today
biden's team dodged that question
is that something that president-elect
biden is considering a four to six week
lockdown
well i think he laid out very clearly
across the course of the campaign the
things that he wants to do to get the
virus under control including
encouraging national mass mandates
including providing resources to small
businesses and schools to ensure that
they can open safely he's put forward
his own plans that
are going to get the virus under control
and are going to get the economy moving
again
obviously he is listening to to the very
best advice from
scientists from doctors greg that dr
osterholm seems to forget the rising
suicides and addictions and
people missing regular cancer screenings
the
the
the hardship that children are
experiencing and all the businesses that
have gone under permanently
well i it's the difference between
single variable thinking
like more cases and all the other things
that are going around in this big
picture of this universe
i do think that they're they're if
they're if they're
basing all of this on increased uh
positivity rates
it's a huge mistake because that is
going to that just reflects
more repetitive testing uh and overlooks
the resiliency of the population the
fact that the death rates are going down
it's like test
it's like testing for arthritis like you
may never know you have arthritis until
they test it and they go you have a
little bit of arthritis like i thought i
had a little eye they did an x-ray you
have a little bit of arthritis there
i never do that it's something that is
just prevalent to your point and it's a
grim
point that i was thinking about last
night i don't think i've experienced
more death in my life than in 2020
in terms of relatives and friends
acquaintances in this year and none of
them were from covid
you know there was uh cancer there was
uh there was pneumonia there was an
overdose
uh and i'm wondering everybody if
everybody sat down and went through
their mental rolodex
of people who passed away
this year you will then be able to
catalog
this the butterfly effect of death right
you change this one thing
shut down everything and then what
happens everything else that butterfly
effect
people are home alone they end up
drinking a lot they can't go to their
aaa meetings
they can't go to any meetings um
there are people that are dying from car
accidents and you think that wouldn't be
the case
but it's because more people there are
fewer people on the road but they're
speeding
we had so many pedestrian deaths in new
york city
and you thought well how could that be
in a lockdown it's because people are
speeding because there's nobody
out there it's weird and sad
sorry no it but it's true and it's
something that clearly this doctor
is just ignoring juan do you think biden
wants to shut down
the economy i don't think anybody wants
that but look i mean there's a certain
reality we have to be in touch with here
right now 10 states 10 states have a new
level of death the rolling seven day
average 10 states
we're talking as the cases hit a
national record on wednesday
hospitalizations more than 65 000 of our
fellow americans and we know about the
death total
more than 200 000. the death toll is a
death rate juan i'm just telling you
right now the death
rate in 10 states is at a record level
greg
and you know i don't think i don't think
trump is
going to be you know remember trump said
no one's going to be talking about the
virus after the election well we're
talking about the virus
because the trends are all in the wrong
direction so when you asked me that
question deagon let's not dodge it
i think that what you see is joe biden
wants to work with the governors the
mayors the scientists
to try to find a way where you don't
have to do a lockdown
but why would you say you don't do a
lockdown if that would save us from
getting sick
and people die you gotta be honest with
people
people are dying they're dying from
suicide they're dying from drug
overdoses they're dying from cancer
because they're not getting screened
we'd never have another car accident
we're not saying stay home for we're
saying
here are logical steps to protect
ourselves as americans why can't we look
out for ourselves and our families
we are but there's an alternative to
shutting down the economy
cuomo writes a book about leadership and
he almost single-handedly killed
thousands of elderly people in new york
jesse well i'm just sorry to hear that
greg has arthritis
you know what greg i'm sure that there's
an advertisement on fox then you could
pick up some of them
really by the way you probably have it
too i just don't know it you just don't
just haven't been checked
my i have been having some achy knees
recently
um listen biden team off to a heck of a
start
you know one advisor says we're gonna
lock down for a month the other says
we're going to give the chinese the
vaccine
before the americans get it um is the
adviser that told lbj to send a half a
million troops to vietnam
is he still around maybe biden could
pick him up or how about the guy that
did the website for obamacare let's put
him in charge of something big
i'm getting the feeling that biden is
surrounding himself by a bunch of idiots
and this is going to be presidency by
committee and if you walk into the white
house with a lab coat on
and tell bine to do something he'll say
okay scientist and he'll do it
this is not good you're gonna have more
czars than you've ever seen i mean biden
doesn't even tweet himself
the guy from msnbc wrote his speech for
saturday night
and went on msnbc and praised it and
didn't say he was the one that wrote the
speech
look at the transition team it's all
silicon valley check their names out
that's who's running the show right now
biden doesn't know what he's doing
well um they say they like dr fauci dr
fauci today
said lockdowns are not necessarily what
we need to do so
that then the second thing i would say
is if you are on the transition team and
you're advising biden
i would say you don't need to go on
cable tv you should save your advice
for biden and then let him take all that
advice
and make a decision from there before
jumping the gun yeah cuomo gatherings of
10 people are less
not based on science not based on
science